Geneviève Darius sec bonjour
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin un
mot d'abord sur le gouvernement qui
présente aujourd'hui son son plan de
sobriété vous concrètement vous faites
quoi dans votre ministère
et bien les lumières sont éteintes la
nuit enfin le soir dès le soir dans tous
les couloirs et c'est un grand ministère
avec de très longs couloirs je pense que
c'est important
et je n'ai pas nous avons tous été
sensibilisés les ministres et toutes les
administrations sur ce sujet et pour
l'instant bien le chauffage n'est pas
allumé puisque les températures sont
clémentes et je pense que cet hiver et
bien le chauffage sera une température
certainement plus basse donc peut-être
que vous porterez une doudoune il y aura
plus d'eau chaude non plus dans votre
ministère
j'ai mis lave les mains et je peux le
faire à l'eau froide
je ne sais pas s'il n'y aura plus d'eau
chaude en tout cas s'il y a des usages
particuliers certainement qu'ils seront
maintenus mais dans une règle générale
nous n'avons pas besoin d'eau chaude et
et vous personnellement qu'est-ce que
vous faites comme éco-geste c'est comme
ça qu'on dit maintenant aujourd'hui
bien écoutez comme beaucoup de Français
je crois je suis attentive aux lumières
qui resterait allumée donc éteindre les
lumières débrancher des appareils
effectivement être vigilant à ces gestes
du quotidien ne pas laisser brancher en
veille un ordinateur toute la nuit donc
ce sont des gestes en fait très facile à
adopter il faut que ça rentre dans la
routine pour tous
c'est aujourd'hui je le disais la
Journée nationale des aidants les
associations elles alertent sur la
dégradation de leurs conditions de vie
et estime que leur statut n'est pas
toujours respectée qu'est-ce que vous
leur répondez à ces associations côté il
y a dans notre pays entre 8 et 10
millions d'aidants et on ne connaît pas
le chiffre exact parce que beaucoup de
personnes ne se considèrent pas comme
aidant alors que ce sont des aidants au
quotidien et puis il y a différents
modes des danses c'est à dire on peut
aider une personne âgée dans sa fin de
vie on peut aider une personne en
situation de handicap
approprié pour les aidants qui pourront
par le fait qu'ils ont aidé donc ils ont
acquis une expérience dans ce domaine là
faire valoir cela pour potentiellement
envisager un métier dans le soin ou dans
l'aide aux personnes âgées mais
imaginons par exemple un cas de figure
que doit faire par exemple des parents
dont leur enfant vient de perdre l'usage
par exemple de ces jambes qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils doivent arrêter de
travailler ils doivent ils doivent se
tourner vers qui comment est-ce qu'ils
peuvent continuer à maintenir leur train
de vie parce que pour 58 euros par jour
c'est sans doute pas suffisant quand
surtout quand on vit à Paris qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent faire ces gens-là
d'autant que la location journalière des
procédants c'est une durée limitée de
trois mois et cela est véritablement
compatible enfin adapté pour des
personnes qui s'arrêtent de façon courte
pour des personnes en situation de
handicap il y a des aides particulières
pour les parents qui ont un enfant
handicapés il y a bien sûr des aides
également pour inclure cet enfant à
l'école ou dans des structures qui
peuvent aider la famille et décharger la
famille mais il faut reconnaître que
c'est toujours un bouleversement dans
une famille toujours un bouleversement
important une vie qui change
effectivement un emploi que souvent on
ne peut plus faire dans les mêmes
conditions et à même avec la même
liberté d'esprit également donc nous
voulons poursuivre cette stratégie pour
les aidants afin de les reconnaître
toujours mieux et surtout leur donner
aussi des moments de répit travailler
sur le répit parce que les aidants sont
souvent fatigués non pas le temps de se
soigner non pas le temps d'avoir une vie
sociale et c'est cela qui nous importe
de pouvoir faire en sorte de les aider
avec ces structures de répit vous
parliez par exemple de l'accueil
notamment des plus jeunes dans les
écoles en cette nouvelle rentrée il y a
beaucoup d'enfants qui qui ont des
handicaps et qui sont encore solutions
adaptées certaines écoles refusent de
les accueillir d'autres ne sont pas
adaptés et puis aussi un manque
d'acompagne d'accompagnant comment on
réussit à améliorer tout ça
l'enjeu était de taille de dire que nous
voulions aller dans une école inclusive
et pourtant c'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire que les enfants en
situation de handicap doivent aller à
l'école et nous avons fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'avancées dans les cinq années
qui viennent de s'écouler avec
aujourd'hui 430 000 enfants qui sont
scolarisés avec 130000 aesh c'est fait
même fameuse personne qui aide ses
enfants dans les écoles alors il y a
toujours des enfants certainement sans
solution c'est vrai à chaque rentrée
scolaire des remontées du terrain nous
montrent cela mais la grande majorité
des enfants ont une solution
ont des aides
aussi des aides matérielles c'est à dire
des outils pour pouvoir apprendre parce
que certains c'est cela qui leur faut
d'autres bien entendu ce sont des
méthodes pédagogiques des enseignants
qui sont à adapter aux handicap et toute
cette palette d'outils nous permet
d'accueillir de plus en plus d'enfants à
l'école nous devons continuer nous ne
sommes pas en plus c'est combien et bien
cette année il y a eu encore donc 40 000
pardon 20 000 enfants supplémentaires et
qui ont été scolarisés donc c'est 430000
je vous le dis sur l'ensemble de la
France et le nombre augmente tous les
ans régulièrement donc moi je veux
saluer l'éducation nationale qui fait
cette inclusion de façon
remarquable nous avons encore des
progrès à faire bien entendu pour
répondre à toutes les situations mais
c'est un engagement de la nation qui est
très très fort auprès des familles et
des enfants un dernier mot rap sur le
taux d'emploi des personnes handicapées
reste toujours deux fois moins important
que celui de l'ensemble de la population
là encore est-ce que vous avez un
dispositif pour changer les choses alors
il y a beaucoup de dispositifs qui
existent et il est vrai que le taux
d'emploi des personnes handicapées est
encore trop élevé il a beaucoup baissé
il est passé de 18% à 14%, mais il n'est
pas à 7% qui est le taux moyen en nous
sommes dans un moment de plein emploi et
je souhaite que les personnes
handicapées participent les entreprises
et bien déjà il faut qu'elle change de
regard sur le handicap il doit y avoir
des référents handicaps dans chaque
entreprise de plus de 250 salariés il y
a des dispositifs d'aide avec qui sont
mises en œuvre par l'Agefiph qui est une
association qui permet de faciliter la
mise en emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap un adaptant les
postes de travail à l'adaptant les
conditions de travail et des aides des
aides à l'emploi sont également
présentes donc il y a une palette
d'outils que nous devons utiliser et le
duod qui aura lieu bientôt au mois de
novembre nous permettra aussi de donner
la visibilité des personnes en situation
de handicap dans l'emploi merci beaucoup
Geneviève Darius et bonne journée à vous
merci à vous